i'll probably be going somewhere
tomorrow where i'll be getting three
square meals a day
and that's okay
i am
i'm okay with that
and i want you to know that i'm not
afraid it is breaking my heart
you guys
i just want you to stay strong
powerful stuff there an organizer of the
freedom convoy delivering that emotional
message hours before being arrested by
police in ottawa that's right and as the
crack down north of the border
intensifies a group of truckers right
here in the usa are preparing to take
their own message straight to president
biden fox news contributor lara trump
joins us live so this uh protest is
coming to america lara convoys will
begin in cleveland columbus fresno
california and there's a reason for this
apparently they're going to be met with
a congressional welcoming committee to
discuss policy changes what do you make
of the situation
uh well first of all i just want to say
thank you to the truckers gosh none of
us realized how much we needed the
truckers until all of this started to
happen um and i don't think harley any
of us are surprised to see this coming
here there have been a lot of rumblings
of this happening but this is a peaceful
protest this is how you do it you don't
burn down police precincts you don't
destroy courthouses and small businesses
and ruin entire cities this is a
peaceful protest and it sounds like
their voices are being we're prepared to
hear them and that's exactly what this
is all about and you know it started in
canada with these truckers but i think
they even knew this was far bigger than
them far bigger than canada and bigger
than just the vaccine mandates this is
about the fact that for two years now it
feels like we have been under
totalitarian rule in so many aspects of
our lives you know kids have lost out on
their education how many people have
lost their jobs we have all it feels
like lost two years of our lives we want
to get back to normal it is time to get
there and man the truckers are stepping
up to the plate to do it so i think
we're all looking forward to what comes
out of the freedom convoy here in
america lara speaking of kids dr anthony
fauci says taking masks off kids in
school still too risky this of course
despite the fact that democrat states
are removing mass mandates all over the
place in cases down 42 percent in a week
is this about science anymore or is this
simply a desperate attempt to stay
relevant by dr fauci
well i'm going to say todd it's probably
the latter when it comes to dr fauci we
know the science we know that if you
compare schools that were masked and
unmasked throughout the entire pandemic
there is virtually no difference in
covid transmissions you just had that
incredible fourth grader from new jersey
macy on earlier in the show man what a
champion she is to get out there and
fight for every kid in america it's time
to take the masks off our kids but i
think todd to your point the reason dr
fauci is not too big on rolling the mass
back now totally for kids is what's he
going to do after the pandemic what
magazine covers is he going to grace
who's going to want to give him an
interview
he's really enjoyed you know riding high
over the past two years of this pandemic
as the king i think he knows when it's
over nobody's going to have time for him
so maybe he's trying to extend it out a
little bit regardless get the mass off
our kids it is absolutely time it's over
yeah well first of all i hope that makes
you still listening because i'm sure
she's going gonna think it's cool that
you were listening to her interview and
mentioned her name um but you know just
a couple more seconds here to you laura
um the cdc even says that
only kn and 95 masks are the things that
prevent omicron spread so why are we why
is uh pouch even doing this
well and carly we know how bad the masks
are for the kids right we know they
can't concentrate they're not learning
anything we know it's socially it's bad
it's bad all around i think it's time
we've all seen for them that's a really
good point yeah absolutely when you talk
about the mental health of kids that's
the most important part hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now